Темою сьогоднішнього
уроку є похідна функція,
її фізичний та геометричний зміст.
Перш ніж ми перейдемо
до визначення похідної,
потрібно розібратись з
деякими допоміжними поняттями.
Тож перейдемо до першого з них.
Поняття приросту функцій та аргументу.
Що таке приріст?
Уявіть собі депозит,
на який поклали гроші,
вкладник хоче дізнатись який прибуток
він отримає за конкретний місяць.
Що йому для цього потрібно зробити?
Він бере суму грошей, яка є в
нього на депозиті на початку місяця,
та суму грошей у кінці місяці
і знаходить їх різницю.
Різниця - це і є приростом його функцій.
Приростом аргументу в даному
випадку буде проміжок часу,
тобто від кінцевого моменту
часу віднімаємо початковий.
Тож,
приріст аргументу функцій F у точці
Х нульове, позначається як дельта Х.
Дельта Х дорівнюватиме Х мінус Х нульове
і звідси ми можемо легко виразити
кінцеве значення аргументу, тобто Х.
Х дорівнюватиме Х нульове плюс дельта Х.
Абсолютно аналогічним чином визначається
приріст функції у точці Х нульове.
Позначається так само дельта F.
Дивимось на дошку.
Перейдемо далі.
Задача про дотичну до графіка функцій.
Що є дотичною?
Давайте розберемося.
Нехай в нас є функція, доволі
вам знайома Y дорівнює Х квадрат,
яка буде у неї дотична у точці нуль,
тобто на початку координат в точці О?
Це буде вісь абсцис, тобто пряма
Y дорівнює нулю. Це всім зрозуміло.
Яке означення дотичної ми з вами знаємо?
Дотична це пряма, яка має з певною
фігурою лише одну спільну точку.
Але так не завжди.
Давайте розглянемо приклад.
Є певна функція, яка
виділена у вас червоним
і в даній точці проведем дотичну.
Всім зрозуміло, що дотичною до
даної функції у цій точці буде дана пряма.
Але, як ви можете побачити, вона
перетинає нашу функцію ще в одній точці.
Тому, визначення дотичної
через одну спільну точку
не є правильним для даної дотичної.
Спробуємо розібратись і
визначити дотичну іншим способом.
Позначаємо точку M на нашій параболі в
довільному місці та проведемо січну ОМ,
тепер будемо зміщувати нашу точку
М вздовж параболи у сторону точки О.
Як при цьому змінюватиметься січна?
Давайте подивимось.
Як ми бачимо, наша пряма -
вона прямує до осі ОХ,
вона прагне стати дотичною.
Вона прагне зайняти це положення.
Назвемо це положення граничним положенням.
дивимось на екран.
Що ще характеризує дотичну?
Дотична має кут нахилу до осі
абсцис і має свій тангенс кута нахилу,
який відповідає за кутовий коефіцієнт.
Оскільки дотична - це пряма, її можна
записати у вигляді Y дорівнює КХ плюс В,
якщо це не вертикальна пряма.
Перейдемо до визначення тангенсу кута.
Почнемо з січної ОМ.
Дивимось на дошку.
Що буде нашим тангенсом?
Проведемо перпендикуляр
з точки М до осі абсцис.
Утворений кут альфа.
Тангенс його кута буде, відповідно,
відношення протилежного
катета до прилеглого.
Що це будуть за катети?
Ці катети будуть – приростом
функцій та приростом аргументу.
Дивимось на дошку.
Бачимо, що
що різниця від кінцевого положення
до початкового - це буде дельта F.
І різниця від кінцевого положення до
початкового аргументу буде дельта Х.
Тому тангенс кута нахилу, нашої
січної, буде дельта F ділене на дельта Х.
Повертаємось до дотичної.
Коли ми рухали точку М до точки О,
то наша січна намагалась
зайняти положення дотичної.
Тобто, прямувала до
граничного свого положення.
Що буде відбуватись з
тангенсом кута нахилу?
Абсолютно все те саме.
Давайте позначимо у якості бета
кут нахилу дотичної у точці О.
Тоді за нашим припущенням, тангенс
бета буде дорівнювати тангенсу альфа,
якщо дельта Х буде прямувати до нуля.
Якщо ми будемо зменшувати різницю
між кінцевим і початковим положення,
ми дійдемо до граничного положення.
Коли наша січна перетвориться в дотичну.
Давайте введемо позначення граничного
положення як ліміт.
Тобто, тангенс бета дорівнює ліміту від
тангенса альфа
при дельта Х прямує до нуля.
Або, ліміту дельта f ділене на
дельта Х, при дельта Х прямує до нуля.
Наступне питання.
Задача про миттєву швидкість.
Уявімо рівноприскорений рух.
Є певний проміжок з відстанню S,
є початкова швидкість, є час, за
який ми проходимо цей проміжок.
Що буде середньою
швидкістю на всьому проміжку?
Середня швидкість – це
весь шлях ділимо на весь час.
Так ми отримаємо середнє значення.
Якщо нас цікавить якийсь
конкретний проміжок,
на допомогу нам прийде приріст.
Власне дельта S,
тобто різниця між відстанями,
які він пройшов до точки S 1 і S2
(приріст S) ділимо на дельта Т.
Відповідно, час, за
який він пройшов до S1,
за який він пройшов до
S 2 від початкової точки
і знаходимо різницю.
Тоді для даного проміжку ми
знайшли весь шлях і весь час.
Це буде середня швидкість
на даному проміжку
якщо ми звузимо цей проміжок і продовжимо
звужувати до його граничного положення.
В якійсь момент часу,
коли ми будемо
зменшувати час, який він їхав,
ми отримаєм точку.
Виглядатиме це так.
Дивимось на дошку.
Граничне положення, коли S 1 і S 2 майже
співпадає, ми отримаємо певний момент
і тоді середня швидкість дорівнюватиме
швидкості саме в цей момент часу.
Тобто, швидкість миттєва
дорівнюватиме дельта S ділене на дельта t
при дельта t прямує до 0.
Формула доволі схожа з
формулою з попередньої задачі.
Ми вже знаємо, як позначається
граничне положення.
Тому V миттєве буде дорівнювати
лімітові дельта t прямує до 0,
дельта S ділене на дельта t.
Ми отримали доволі схожий результат.
Насправді ці задачі описують
майже одне і те саме явище, а саме:
попередня задача про дотичну
описує рух матеріальної точки.
В даному випадку - відстань,
яку проходить наша точка,
за неї буде відповідати
значення функції f.
Тобто по Y.
А за час, за який вона все це
проходить, відповідає аргумент X.
Ми отримаємо зображення як точка
М рухається вздовж нашої параболи.
Тому швидкість в момент
дотичної визначатиметься
за такою самою формулою.
Отже вводимо поняття похідної.
Ми отримали дві доволі цікаві формули.
Що швидкість в момент
часу дорівнюватиме ліміт
при дельта t прямує до 0 від
дельта S ділене на дельта t.
Де, відповідно, S - це функція,
яка залежить від аргументу t.
Та тангенс кута нахилу дотичної
дорівнює ліміт, дельта Х прямує
до 0, дельта f ділене на дельта x.
Де F, відповідно, функція,
яка залежить від Х.
Давайте дамо означення похідної.
Дивимось на екран.
Похідною функції f у точці х нульове
називають число, яке дорівнює границі
Дивимось на екран.
відношення приросту функції f у точці х
нульове до відповідного приросту аргументу
за умови, що приріст
аргументу прямує до 0.
Саме ці дві формули відповідають за
похідну функції S та похідну функції f.
Відповідне позначення,
де приріст розписаний як
f від кінцевого положення,
які ми визначаємо як початкове,
плюс приріст аргументу,
мінус f від початкового положення,
ділене на приріст аргументу.
Похідна має два змісти.
Перший – це фізичний зміст.
Ми з вами визначили,
що похідна від функції S
дорівнюватиме миттєвій
швидкості у точці t нульове.
Другий зміст похідної. Геометричний.
Похідна від функції f в точці х нульове
дорівнюватиме тангенсу кута нахилу
дотичної до даної функції в цій точці.
Як ми вже згадували, то
тангенс кута нахил дотичної
відповідає за кутовий коефіцієнт дотичної.
Давайте знайдемо якісь конкретні похідні
і розберемо приклад функції х квадрат.
Похідна від х квадрат має
дорівнювати відношенню f
від кінцевого положення аргументу.
Ми розписуємо як початкове, плюс приріст.
Дивимось уважно.
І просто підставляємо до нашої формули.
Замість х підставляємо
х нульове плюс дельта х,
мінус х нульове в квадраті.
Розкриваємо дужки за формулою.
Отримаємо
х нульове в квадраті плюс подвоєний
добуток два х нульове дельта х
плюс дельта х в квадраті
мінус х нульове в квадраті,
скорочуємо х нульове в квадраті,
отримаємо ліміт при
дельта х прямує до нуля,
2 х нульове дельта х
плюс дельта х в квадраті.
Тепер скорочуємо на дельта
х кожен доданок окремо.
Ми отримаємо 2 х нульове плюс дельта х.
Згадуємо, що ліміт нашої
функції прямує до 0.
Точніше, при дельта х прямує до 0.
Тому ліміт дорівнюватиме 2 х нульове.
Похідна від функцій х квадрат
у точці х нульове дорівнюватиме
2 х нульове.
Знаходити похідну окремо для
кожної функції не є потрібним.
Всі ці похідні вже виведені.
Ми з вами просто розглянемо деякі з них.
Дивимось на екран.
Похідна існує, наприклад, від функції
х в степені n, де n є будь яким числом.
Похідна дорівнюватиме n
помножене на х в степені n мінус 1.
Похідна від кореня з х
дорівнюватиме 1 ділене на 2 кореня з х.
Похідна від синуса буде косинус х та
похідна від косинуса буде мінус синус х.
Переходимо до практичної частини.
Перший приклад.
Потрібно знайти похідну функції.
Використовувати ми будемо
лише функції по типу х в степені n.
Перший приклад.
Y дорівнює х в десятому.
За формулою похідної, степінь
має винестись в якості множника
та сама зменшитесь на одиничку.
Тому - дорівнює 10х в 9 степені.
Другий приклад.
Y дорівнює х в степені сім шостих.
Визначаємо похідну.
Степінь виноситься в якості коефіцієнту
і сама степінь стає меншою на одиницю.
Похідна дорівнюватиме сім
шостих х в степені одна шоста.
Третій приклад.
Y дорівнює корінь кубічний із х.
У формулах похідної ми
бачили лише корінь квадратний.
Що робити з коренем кубічним?
З властивостей степенів ви знаєте,
що корінь кубічний із х можна представити
у вигляді х в степені одна третя.
Тоді похідна перетворюється на похідну від
звичайної функції по типу х в степені n.
Одна третя виноситься
в якості коефіцієнту,
це буде (1/3)х в
степені на одиничку менше,
тобто х в степені мінус дві треті.
Наступний приклад.
Обчислити значення
похідної в заданій точці.
Y дорівнює синус х, сама точка х
нульове дорівнюватиме 60 градусів.
Похідною від синуса х є косинус х.
Знаходимо цю похідну.
Потрібно просто підставити точку
60 градусів у значення нашої похідної.
Отримаємо косинус 60
градусів якій дорівнює одна друга.
Наступний приклад.
Корінь кубічний із х
при х нульове дорівнює 0.
З попереднього прикладу
ми з вами дізнались
як знаходить похідну від кореня
кубічного з х, а саме як х одна третя.
Це буде одна третя х
мінус х в степені дві третіх
і підставляємо точку нуль замість х.
Отримаємо:
дорівнює 0.
Наступний приклад.
Знайдіть за допомогою графіка
функцій значення f штрих від х1,
та f штрих від х2.
Згадуємо геометричний зміст похідної.
Похідна функцій у точці
дорівнює кутовому коефіцієнту дотичної,
або тангенсу кута нахилу дотичної.
Що ми можемо сказати про точку х1.
Дотична в цій точці паралельна осі абсцис.
Отже кут нахилу дорівнюватиме 0.
Відповідно і тангенс 0 дорівнюватиме 0.
Отже, і значення нашої
похідної у даній точці.
З приводу дотичної у точці х два.
Вона утворює з додатнім
напрямком осі абсцис кут 30 градусів.
Відповідно,
тангенс 30 градусів дорівнюватиме
1 ділене на корінь із 3.
Так ми знайшли значення
похідних у даних точках.
Розглянемо декілька прикладів
обчислення похідної в точці.
Дивимось на дошку.
Перший приклад.
Для розв’язання перших прикладів
нам знадобиться така формула.
Похідна від х в степені n
дорівнюватиме nх в степені n мінус 1.
Перший приклад.
Похідна від х в 1О степені.
За формулою ми маємо нашу
степінь винести в якості коефіцієнту.
Це буде 1О і помножити на х
в степені на одиничку меншу.
Тобто х в 9 степені.
Тому похідна від х в 1О степені
дорівнюватиме 1О на х в 9.
Другий приклад.
Х в степені сім шостих.
Степінь, яка була,
виноситься в якості коефіцієнту.
Тобто,
сім шостих
множимо на х в степені на одиницю менше,
х в степені одна шоста.
Третій приклад.
Похідна від кореня кубічного з х.
У формулах у нас був
присутній корінь квадратний з х.
Похідна від нього дорівнювала
1 ділити на 2 кореня з х.
Що буде з кубічним коренем?
Ви знаєте з властивостей степенів, що
корінь кубічний з х можна представити
у вигляді х степені одна третя.
Якщо ми представимо корінь кубічний
з х у вигляді х в степені одна третя,
то ми легко можемо знайти
похідну за даною формулою
Одна третя виноситься у якості коефіцієнту
і множиться на х в
степені на одиницю менше.
Одна третя мінус 1
відповідно буде мінус дві третіх.
Наступне.
Знаходження значення
похідної в певній точці.
Перший приклад.
Y дорівнюватиме синус х
і х нульове дорівнюватиме 60 градусів.
Для обчислення цієї похідної використаємо
формулу обчислення похідної для синуса.
Власне, синус х похідна
дорівнюватиме косинус х.
Знаходимо похідну: y штрих
Тепер необхідно підставити
х нульове у дану функцію,
власне, у похідну від
нашої початкової функції.
Тобто, y штрих від 60 градусів
дорівнюватиме косинус 60 градусів
дорівнює одна друга.
Ми знайшли значення похідної у точці 60.
Пригадаємо геометричний
зміст цієї похідної.
Що таке похідна в
точці для певної функції?
Це – кутовий коефіцієнт
дотичної, або тангенс кута нахилу.
Що це означає для нашої функції синус х.
Зараз продемонструю.
Дивимось на дошку.
Зробимо графік для синус х.
Беремо 60 градусів, це Пі на 3.
Пі на 3 знаходимиться приблизно тут.
Дивимось на дошку.
Якщо ми проведемо
дотичну до графіку функцій
Дивимось на дошку.
У даній точці,
То кутовий коефіцієнт нахилу даної
прямої дорівнюватиме одна друга.
Це означатиме, що нашу
пряму можна записати у вигляді:
y дорівнює одна друга х плюс б.
Ставлячи точку, через яку вона проходить,
ми можемо відновити рівняння дотичної.
Наступний приклад.
В якому ми будемо знаходити
значення похідної у заданій точці.
Y дорівнює корінь із х
помножений на корінь х
у точці х нульове, дорівнює 1.
Перша дія для розв’язання
цього прикладу буде взяти похідну.
Але у нас немає табличного
значення похідної для даної функції.
Але ми можемо її
перетворити у певний вигляд,
який співпадає з табличним значенням.
Тож, y дорівнює
х помножити на х в степені одна друга,
і весь вираз буде в степені одна друга.
За властивістю степенів ми
можемо дізнатись чому дорівнює
вираз у середині дужок.
Це х в 1 степені множиться
на х в степені одна друга.
Тоді степені ми маємо додати, щоб
дізнатись, в якій степені буде х.
Відповідно, це буде х в
степені 1 плюс одна друга,
дорівнюватиме три других
і все це підносимо до степеню одна друга.
За правилом розкриття дужок,
у степенях ми маємо помножити
першу степінь на другу степінь,
відповідно отримаємо х
у степені три четвертих.
Тепер
ця функція відповідає
абсолютно нашій першій функції,
яку ми сьогодні розглядали.
Тобто х в степені n.
Беремо похідну
y штрих дорівнює три четвертих,
х в степені три четвертих мінус один,
тобто мінус одна четверта,
дорівнює,
підставляємо нашу точку:
Дивимось на дошку.
Точку 1,
дорівнюватиме три четвертих.
Дивимось на дошку.
Кутовий коефіцієнт дотичної
до даної функції у точці
х нульове дорівнює 1,
буде дорівнювати три четвертих.
Розглянемо наступний
приклад на знаходження похідної.
Дивимось на дошку.
Y дорівнює х в 5 помножений на корінь із х
ділене на х в степені 3,
помножене на корінь кубічний х.
Точка х нульове дорівнює одна друга.
Звертаємось до властивостей степенів, щоб
претворити функцію на вираз х в степені n
Y дорівнює
х в 5 помножити на х в степені одна друга,
ділимо на х в кубі,
помножити на х в степені одна третя.
За властивістю степенів,
при множенні двох виразів у
степені, ми маємо ці степені додати.
Тож чисельник
х у степені 5 плюс одна друга
і знаменник х у степені
3 плюс одна третя.
Дорівнює х в степені 5 цілих одна друга на
х в степені 3 цілих одна третя.
Ми маємо від степені чисельника
відняти степінь знаменника.
Буде дорівнювати х у степені 5 цілих
одна друга мінус 3 цілих одна третя.
Зводимо до спільного знаменника 6,
маємо помножити цей дріб на 3
і цей дріб на 2.
Отримаємо
3 мінус 2 буде 1 в чисельнику.
В знаменнику буде 6
і цілі частини 5 мінус 3 буде два.
Тобто х у
степені 2 цілих одна шоста.
Знаходимо похідну за
правилом х в степені n.
Y штрих дорівнює
2 цілих одна шоста х в
степені 1 ціла одна шоста
і підставляємо нашу точку - одна друга.
Дорівнює
2 цілих одна шоста на одну
другу в степені 1 ціла одна шоста.
Отримали відповідь.
Я вже чую дзвоник.
І мені здається, на
цьому пора завершувати.